but we're going to begin with potential
new trouble for the economy ahead
following the worst day for stocks since
june of 2020. the major markets all
plunged yesterday with the nasdaq down
the most more than five percent
all because a key government report
showed less improvement in the fight
against inflation than expected at the
same time there is a looming threat of a
railway strike which could have a big
impact on supply chains ed o'keefe is
following it all for us at the white
house and the president cannot be happy
about any of it good morning no he
cannot tony good morning that inflation
report uh dashes hopes of a quicker
economic rebound and while the stock
market goes up and down all the time
this one day drop for most indexes was
the biggest since the early months of
the covet 19 pandemic
even though the average price of gas is
down 26 cents in the last month other
prices aren't falling government figures
show groceries climbing more than 13
percent on average electricity spiking
nearly 16 percent and rent up nearly 7
percent over the last year
those high prices plus the likelihood
the federal reserve will raise interest
rates again sent the markets tumbling
just as the president and democrats were
celebrating passage of their inflation
reduction act a single most important
legislation passed in the congress to
combat inflation and one of the most
significant laws in our nation's history
in my view the new law provides funding
to fight climate change ease health care
costs and hike taxes on big corporations
but it does nothing to address short
price hikes the president said last
night he isn't worried the stock market
doesn't necessarily reflect the state of
the economy i think we're going to be
fine republicans disagree these numbers
are staggering and the white house seems
to be just an absolute denial and now
washington is preparing for another
development that could slam the brakes
on an economic rebound nearly 30 percent
of all u.s freight shipments could be
halted by friday if the nation's
railroads can't cut a deal with unions
at odds over sick time and attendance
policies one of the last things we need
is more difficulties in getting
agriculture commodities and food
amtrak is preemptively canceling
long-haul service on affected tracks and
some commuter rail lines are warning
customers make alternative plans
beginning friday the effects of it
compound very quickly over the course of
even a few days so things that you're
used to getting
all of a sudden sort of aren't there
anymore on a grocery shelf
now while the economy and inflation
remain the top issues of concern for
voters we've noticed abortion rights has
also become a big concern and that's
what was so curious about what senator
lindsey graham of south carolina
proposed yesterday he's unveiled the
proposed national ban
on abortion rights his bill would ban
the procedure after 15 weeks of
pregnancy with rare exceptions it has no
chance of becoming law as long as
democrats control congress and when
asked even minority leader mitch
mcconnell wouldn't commit to holding a
vote on the proposal if the gop retakes
senate control he noted most republican
senators believe each state not the
federal government should determine what
to do about abortion and of course he's
seen the polls show a majority of
americans do not support a national ban
on abortion rights tony
abortion big issue on the campaign trail
this year but of course the economy is
as well ed thank you very much